The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
Let's get going here.
So this is a lecture that's
actually appropriate for
Halloween, because it's
a scary topic.
Non-deterministic programming.
So we've been looking mostly
at deterministic programs.
So a program is deterministic
on a given input if every
memory location is updated
with the same sequence of
values in every execution.
So if you look at the memory of
the machine, you can view
that as, essentially, the
state of the machine.
And if you're always updating
every memory location with
exactly the same sequence of
values, then the program is
deterministic.
Now it may be that two memory
locations may be updated in a
different order.
So you may have one location
which is updated first in one
execution, and another that's
second, and then in a
different execution, they may
be a different order.
That's OK, generally.
The issue is whether or not
every memory location sees the
same order.
And if they do, then it's for
every execution, then it's a
deterministic program.
So what's the advantage
of having a
deterministic program?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It always runs the
same way [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It always
runs the same way.
So what?
What's that good for?
AUDIENCE: So you can
find bugs easier.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, debugging.
It's really easy to find bugs
if every time you run it it
does the same thing.
It's much harder to find bugs
if, when you run it, it might
do something different.
So that leads to our first
major rule of thumb about
determinism, which is you
should always write
deterministic programs.
Don't write
non-deterministic programs.
And the only problem is, boy
is that poor quality there.
So basically, it says, always
write non-deterministic
programs unless you can't.
So sometimes, the only way to
get performance is to do
something non-deterministic.
So this lecture is basically
about some of the ways of
doing non-deterministic
programming.
So it's appropriate that we say
this is not for those who
are faint of heart.
We are treading into dangerous
territory here.
So the basic rule is, as I say,
any time you can, make
your program deterministic.
So we're going to talk about the
number one way that people
introduce non-determinism into
programs, which is via mutual
exclusion and mutexes, which are
a type of lock, and then
look at some of the anomalies
that you get.
Besides just things being
non-deterministic, you can
also get some very, very
weird behavior
sometimes for the execution.
So we'll start out with
mutual exclusion.
So let's take a look, for
example, suppose I'm
implementing a hash table
as a set of bins.
And I'm resolving collisions
with chaining.
So here, each slot of my hash
table has a chain of all the
values that resolve
to that slot.
And if I have a value x, let's
say it has key 81, and I want
to insert x into the table, I
first compute a hash of x.
And let's say it hashes to this
particular list here.
And then what I do is
I say, OK, let me
insert x into the table.
So I make the next pointer of
x point to whatever is the
head of the table.
And then I make the
table 0.2x.
And that effectively inserts
x into the hash table.
Fairly straightforward
piece of code.
I would expect that most of you
could write that even on
an exam and get it right.
But what happens when we say,
oh, let's have some
concurrency.
Let's have the ability to look
up things in a hash table in
different parallel branches
of a parallel program.
So here, we have a concurrent
hash table now where I've got
two values, and I'm going to
have two different threads
inserting x and y.
So one of them is going to do
this one, and one of them is
going to do this one.
So let's just see how
this can screw up.
So first, we hash x,
and it hashes to
this particular slot.
So then we do, just as we're
doing before, making its next
pointer point to the beginning
of the array.
Then y gets in the picture,
and it decides oh,
I'm going to hash.
And oh, it hashes to exactly
the same slot.
And then y makes its next
pointer point to the same to
the head of the list.
And then it sets the head of
the list to point to y.
So now y is in the list.
Whoops, now x puts itself in the
list, effectively taking y
out of the list.
So rather than x and y both
being in the list, we have a
concurrency bug.
So this is clearly a race.
So it's a determinacy race,
because we have two parallel
instructions accessing
essentially the same location,
at least one of which-- in
this case both of them--
performing a store
to that location.
So that's a determinacy race.
And how things are going to work
out depends upon which
one of these guys goes first.
Notice, as with most race bugs,
that if this code all
executed before this
code, we're OK.
Or if this code all executed
before this code, we're OK.
So the bug occurs when they
happen to execute at
essentially the same time and
their instructions interleave.
So this is a race bug.
So one of the classic ways of
fixing this kind of race bug
is to insist on some kind
of mutual exclusion.
So a critical section is a piece
of code that is going to
access shared data that must not
be executed by two threads
at the same time.
So it shouldn't be accessed by
two threads at the same time.
So it's mutual exclusion.
So that's what a critical
section is.
And we have a mechanism
that operating
systems typically provide--
as well as runtime systems, but
you can build your own--
called "mutexes," or "mutex
locks," or sometimes just
"locks." So a mutex is an object
that has a lock and
unlock member function.
And any attempt by a thread to
lock an already locked mutex
causes that thread to block.
And "block" is, by the way,
a hugely overused word in
computer science.
In this case, by "block," they
mean "wait." It waits until
the mutex is unlocked.
So whenever you have something
that's locked, somebody else
comes and tries to
grab the lock.
The mutex mechanism
only allows one
thread to access it.
The other one waits until
the lock is freed.
Then this other one
can go access it.
So what we can do is build a
concurrent hash table by
modifying each slot in the table
to have both a mutex, L,
and a pointer called "head"
to the slot contents.
And then the idea is that
what we'll do is hash
the value to a slot.
But before we access the
elements of the slot, we're
going to grab the lock
on the slot.
So every slot in the table
has a lock here.
Now, I could have a lock
on the whole table.
What's the problem with that?
Sure.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
basically can't do anything.
You can't read.
You couldn't be reading
from the table.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so
if you have a lock
on the whole table--
AUDIENCE: You would defeat
the purpose [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: You defeat the
purpose of trying to have a
concurrent hash table, right?
Because only one thread can
actually access the
hash table at a time.
So in this case, what we'll do
is we'll lock each slot of the
hash table.
And there are actually
mechanisms where you can lock
each element of the
hash table or a
constant number of elements.
But basically, what we're trying
to do is make it so
that the odds are that if you
have a big enough table and
relatively few processors you're
running on, the odds
that they'll conflict are
going to be very low.
So what we do is we grab a lock
on the slot, and then we
play the same game of inserting
ourselves at the head.
And then we unlock the slot.
So what that does is it means
that only one of the two
threads in the previous example
can actually execute
this code at a time.
And so it guarantees that the
two regions of code will
either execute in this order or
in this order, and you'll
never get the instructions
interleaved.
Now, this is introducing
non-determinism.
Why is this going to be
non-deterministic?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] lock
first, it'll be [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, depending upon
which one gets the lock
first, the length list in there
will have the elements
in a different order.
So a program that depends on
the order of that list is
going to behave differently
from run to run.
So let's recall the definition
of a determinacy race.
It occurs when two logically
parallel instructions access
the same memory location,
and at least one of the
instructions performs a write.
So that is, we do have a
determinacy race when we
introduce locks.
Locks are essentially, we're
going to have an intentional
determinacy race.
So a program execution with no
determinacy races means the
program is deterministic
on that input.
So if there are no determinacy
races, then although
individual locations may be
updated in a different order
in a parallel execution, every
memory location will be
updated by exactly the same
thing at the same time.
The order will be of update
of operations on any given
location will be the
same always.
So that's actually a theorem,
which we're
not going to prove.
But I think if you think
about it, it's fairly
straightforward.
If you never have two guys in
parallel that could possibly
affect the same location, then
the behavior always is going
to be the same thing.
Things are going to get written
in the same order.
So the program in that case
always behaves the same on
that given input, no
matter how it's
scheduled and executed.
We'll always have essentially
the same behavior, even though
it may get scheduled
one way or another.
And one of the nice things
that we have in our race
detection tool Cilkscreen is
that if we do have determinacy
races that exist in
an ostensibly
deterministic program--
that is, a program
with no mutexes.
If basically it just reads and
writes on locations and so
forth, then Cilkscreen
guarantees
to find such a race.
So It's nice that we get a
guarantee out of Cilkscreen.
So this is all beautiful,
elegant, everything works out
great if there are no
determinacy races.
But when we do something like a
concurrent hash table, we're
intentionally putting in
a determinacy area.
So that asks sort of
a natural question.
Why would I want to have a
concurrent hash table?
Why not make it so that my
program is deterministic?
Why might a concurrent hash
table be an advantageous thing
to have in a program that
you wanted to go fast?
Some ideas?
Where might you want
to use it?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Speed?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, speed.
But I mean, what's
an application?
What's a use case, as the
entrepreneurs would ask you?
Where is it that you would
really want to use a
concurrent hash table
to give you speed?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If you started
using it [INAUDIBLE]
along with your system
[INAUDIBLE]
values.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it could be
that there's some sort of
global table that you want a
lot of people to be able to
access at one time.
So if you lock down and only had
one thread accessing at a
time, you reduce how
much concurrency
that you could have.
That's a good one.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Perhaps most of the
time, people are just reading.
So if you had something
concurrent, your reading
should be fine.
So in that case, a lot more
reading high performance
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so in fact,
there's a type of lock called
a reader-writer lock, which
allows one writer to operate,
but many readers.
So that's another type of
concurrency control.
So just another place, a common
place that you use it,
is when you're memoizing.
Meaning I do a computation, I
want to remember the results
so that if I see it again, I
can look it up rather than
having to compute it
again from scratch.
So you might keep all those
values in a hash table.
Well, if I go in the hash table,
now I'm going to have
concurrent accesses to that
hash table if I've got a
parallel program that wants
to do memorizing.
And there are a bunch
of other cases.
So we have determinacy races.
And we have a great guarantee
that if there is a race, we
guarantee to find it.
Now, there's another type of
race, and in fact, you'll hear
more about this type of race
if you read the literature
than you hear about
determinacy races.
So a data race occurs when you
have two logically parallel
instructions holding
no locks in common.
And they access the same
location, and at least one of
the instructions performs
a write.
So this is saying that
I've got accesses.
And if they have no
locks in common--
so it could be that you have
a problem where one of them
holds a lock L, and another
one holds L prime.
And then they access the
location, that's going to be a
data race, because they don't
hold locks in common.
But if I have L and L being the
locks that the two threads
hold, and they access the
same location, that's
not a data race now.
It is a determinacy race,
because it's going to matter
which order it is, but it's not
a data race, because the
locks, in some sense, are
protecting access.
So Cilkscreen, in fact,
understands locks and will not
report a determinacy race unless
it is also a data race.
However, since codes that use
locks are non-deterministic by
intention, they actually weaken
Cilkscreen's guarantee.
And in particular, in its
execution that it does, if it
finds a data race, it's going
to say, I'm going to ignore
that data race.
But now it is only going to
follow one of the two paths
that might arise from
that data race.
In other words, it doesn't
follow both paths.
If you could think about it,
when one of them wins--
so you have a race between
two critical sections.
When one of them wins, you can
imagine that's one possible
outcome of the computation.
When the other wins,
it's another path.
And what Cilkscreen does
is it picks one path.
In fact, it picks the path which
is the one that would
occur in the cereal execution.
So there's a whole path there
that you're not exploring.
So Cilkscreen's guarantee is not
going to be strong there.
However, if the critical
sections, in fact, commute--
that is, they do exactly
the same thing, no
matter what the order.
So for example, if they're both
incrementing a value,
then the result, after doing one
versus after the other is
the same value, then you get a
guarantee out of Cilkscreen.
So Cilkscreen could still be
very helpful for finding bugs,
because typically, when you
organize your computation, if
it occurs in this order,
there's typically some
execution or input where you can
make things occur in the
other order.
So you can actually cover more
races than you might imagine
on first blush.
But it is a danger.
But what we're talking about
today is dangerous
programming, non-deterministic
programming.
So when you start using
mutexes, some of the
guarantees and so forth
get much dicier.
Any questions about that?
Now, if you have no data races
in your code, that doesn't
mean that you have no bugs.
So for example, here's a way
somebody might fix that
insertion code.
So we hash the key, we grab a
lock, we set x next to be
whatever is the head
of the list, and
then we do an unlock.
And now we lock it again.
Now we follow the
head to set x--
sorry, we set x to be
the head of the list
and then unlock again.
And now notice that in this
case, technically, there is no
data race if I have two
concurrent threads trying to
access these at a time, because
all the axis I'm
doing, I'm holding lock L.
Nevertheless, I can get that
same interleaving of code
that causes the bug.
So just because you don't have
a data race doesn't mean that
you don't have a bug
in your code.
As I say, this is dangerous
programming.
However, typically, if you
have mutexes and no data
races, usually it means that you
went through and thought
about this code.
And if you were thinking about
this code, you would say, gee,
really I'm trying to make these
two instructions be the
critical section.
Why would I unlock
and lock again?
So most of the time, as a
practical matter, if you don't
have data races, it probably
means you did the right thing
in terms of identifying the
critical sections that needed
to be locked and not unlocking
things in the middle of them.
So as a practical matter, no
data races usually means it's
unlikely you have bugs.
But no guarantees.
As I say, dangerous
programming.
Non-deterministic programming
is dangerous program.
Any questions about that?
Anybody scared off yet?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So what you can
do is the opposite.
You don't have any bugs, but
you made the critical
distinction to [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yes, so certainly
from a performance point of
view, one of the problems
with locking is that--
and we'll talk about this
a little bit later--
with locking is that if you have
a large section that you
decide to lock, it means
other threads can't do
work on that section.
So they're spinning,
wasting cycles.
So generally, you want
to try to lock
things as small as possible.
The other problem is, it turns
out that there's overhead
associated with these locks.
So if there's overhead
associated with the locks,
that's problematic as well,
because now you
may be slowing down.
If this is in an inner loop,
notice that we've now, even if
I just have the lock and unlock
without these two
spurious ones here, we
may be more than
doubling the overhead.
In fact, locking instructions
tend to be much more expensive
than register operations.
They usually cost something on
the order of going to L2 cache
as a minimum.
So it's not even L1 cache.
It's like going out
to L2 cache.
Now, it turns out there
are some times where
you have data races.
So we say if there are no data
races, then you have no
guarantee there's no bugs.
If there are data races, your
program still may be correct.
Here's an example of a code
where you might want to allow
a benign data race.
So here we have, let's say,
an array A that has these
elements in it.
And we want to find,
what is the set of
digits in the array?
So these are all going to be
values between 0 and 9.
And I want to know which
ones are present of
the digits 0 to 9.
Which ones are not present?
So I can write a little
code for that.
Let me initialize an array
called "digits" to have
all-zero entries.
And now let me go through all
the elements of A and set
digits of whatever the
digit is to be 1.
So set at 1 if that
digit is present.
And I can do that in
parallel, even.
So what can happen here is I can
have, if I've done this in
parallel, this particular update
of digits of 6 will be
set to 1 when this one
is being sent to 1.
Is that a problem?
In some sense, no.
They're both being set to 1.
Who cares?
But there is a race there.
There is a race, but
it's a benign race.
Well, it may or may
not be benign.
So there's a gotcha
on this one.
So this code only works
correctly if the hardware
writes the array elements
atomically.
So for example, not
on the x86-64
architecture we're using.
But on some architectures, you
cannot write a byte value.
You cannot write a byte value
as an atomic operation.
It implements a right to a
byte by reading a word,
masking out things, changing the
field, masking again, and
then writing it back out.
So you can have a race
on a byte value.
In particular, even if I were
going to do this with bits, I
could have a race on bits,
although C doesn't let me
access bits directly.
The smallest unit I can
access is a byte.
So you have to worry about
what's the level of atomicity
provided by your architecture?
So the x86 architecture, the
grain size of atomic update is
you can do a single-byte write,
and it will do the
right, proper thing--
do the right thing
on the write.
So we have both things.
No bugs.
No data races doesn't
mean no bugs.
Presence of data races doesn't
mean you have bugs.
But generally, they're fairly
well overlapped.
Now, why would I not want to put
in a lock and unlock here
just to get rid of the race?
If I run Cilkscreen on this,
it's going to complain.
It's going to say, you've
got a race here.
Why would I not want to put a
lock on here, for example?
AUDIENCE: Because then we don't
have parallelism anymore?
PROFESSOR: No, well, I'd have
parallelism maybe up to 10,
for example, right?
Because I have 10 different
things that could be
going on at a time.
But that's one reason.
That is one reason.
What's another reason why
I might not want to
put locks in here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It could be that
all the numbers--
that's a case where it doesn't
get me much speedup.
But what's another reason
I might want to do this?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I think you're
on the right track.
Overhead.
Yeah.
This is my inner loop.
So if I'm locking and unlocking,
all this is doing
is just doing a memory
[? dereference ?]
and an assignment.
And that may be fairly cheap,
whereas if I grab a lock and
then release the lock, those
operations may be much, much
more expensive.
So I may be slowing down the
execution of this loop by more
than I'm going to gain out of
the parallelism of this.
So I may say, I may reason, hey,
there is a good reason
why not have a data
race there.
So I may want to have a data
race, and I may want
to say that's OK.
And if that happens, however,
you're now going to get
warnings out of Cilkscreen.
And I generally recommend that
you have no warnings on
Cilkscreen when you
run your code.
So the Cilk environment provides
a mechanism called
"fake locks." So a fake lock
allows you to communicate to
Cilkscreen that a race
is intentional.
So what you then do is you put
a fake lock in around this
access here.
And what happens is when
Cilkscreen runs, it says, oh,
you grabbed this lock, so I
shouldn't report a race.
But during execution, no lock
is actually grabbed, because
it's a fake one.
So it doesn't slow you down it
all at runtime, but Cilkscreen
still thinks that a lock
is being acquired.
Questions about that?
So this is if you want to have
an intentional race, this is a
way you can quiet Cilkscreen.
Of course, it's dangerous,
right?
It's yet another example of
what's dangerous here.
Because what happens if
you did it wrong?
What happens if there really
is a bug there?
You're now telling it
to ignore that bug.
So one way that you can
make your code--
if you put in fake locks
everywhere, you could make it
so, oh, Cilkscreen runs just
great, and have your code full
of race bugs.
So if you use fake locks, you
should document very carefully
that you're doing so and why
that's going to be a safe
thing to do.
Any questions about that?
By the way, one of the nice
things about some of the
concurrency platforms like Cilk
is that they provide a
layer of abstraction where
generally, you don't have to
do very much locking.
If you program with Pthreads,
for example, you're locking
all the time.
So you're writing
non-deterministic programs all
the time, and you're debugging
non-deterministic
programs all the time.
Whereas Cilk provides a layer
of programming where you can
do most of your programming in
a deterministic fashion.
And occasionally, you may want
to have some non-determinism
here or there.
But hopefully you can manage
that if you do it judiciously.
Any questions about
mutexes and uses
for them and so forth?
Good.
So let's talk about how
they get implemented.
Because as with all these
things, we want to understand
not just what the abstractions
is but how it is that you
actually implement these things
so that you can reason
about them more cogently.
So there's typically three major
properties of mutexes
when you look at them.
And when you see documentation
for mutexes, you should
understand what the difference
is of these things.
The first is whether it's
a yielding mutex
or a spinning mutex.
So a yielding mutex, when you
spin, it returns control to
the operating system.
And why might you
want to do that?
Whereas a spinning one just
consumes processor cycles.
Why would you want to do that?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
allow other threads.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it can allow
other threads or other jobs
that could be running
to use the processor
while you're waiting.
What's the downside of that?
To speak to the-- either one.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: It might be possible
that whatever you're trying to
do is essential, and you really
want to get that done
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] everything
else executes.
So you really want [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, context
switching a thread out is a
heavyweight operation.
And It may be, if you end up
context switching out, it may
be you only had to wait for a
half a dozen cycles and you'd
have the lock.
But instead, now you're going
and you're doing a context
switch and may not get access
to the machine for another
hundredth of a second
or something.
So it may be on the order of
10 to the 6th-- a million
instructions before you
get access again,
rather than just a few.
The second property of mutexes
is whether they're
reentrant or not.
So a reenttrant mutex allows a
thread that's holding a lock
to acquire it again.
So I may hold the lock, and then
I may try to acquire the
lock again.
Java is full of reentrant locks,
reentrant mutexes.
So why is this a positive
or negative?
What are the pros and
cons of this one?
Why might reentrancy be
a good thing to want?
Why would I bother doing--
why would I grab a lock
that I already have?
AUDIENCE: It'd be too easy to
do a check [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It lets
you do what?
AUDIENCE: It lets you not have
to worry about locking when
you already have a lock.
PROFESSOR: It lets you
not worry about it.
That's right.
But why is that valuable?
AUDIENCE: It saves you one
line in an If statment to
check if you have
a lock or not.
PROFESSOR: That could be.
Basically, the If statement
is embedded in there.
But why would I care?
Why would I want to be acquiring
something that I
already have?
In what programming situation
might that arise?
This seems kind of
weird, right?
Could be recursion.
Yeah.
So usually, what it comes from
is when you have objects, and
you have several methods
on the object.
And what you'd like to do is,
if somebody's calling the
method from the outside, you
would like to be able to
execute that particular--
I guess in C++ they don't call
them "methods." They call them
"member functions." "Member
functions," they call them.
In Java, they call them
"methods," and in C++, they
call them "member functions."
Doesn't matter.
It's the same thing.
So when you access one of these,
normally, from the
outside, you want to make sure
you grab the lock associated
with the object.
However, it may be that what
you're doing inside the object
is you want to be able--
one of the operations may be a
more complex operation that
wants to use one of its
own implementations.
So rather than implementing
it twice--
once in the locked form, once
without getting the lock--
you just implement it once, and
you use reentrant locks.
And that way, you don't have
to worry about, in coding
those things, whether or not
you've already got it.
So that's probably the most
common place that I know that
people want reentrant locks.
Naturally, to acquire a
reentrant lock, you have to do
some kind of If statement,
which is a conditional.
And as you know, if it's an
unpredictable branch, that's
going to be very expensive.
So generally, there is a cost
to making it reentrant.
The third property is whether
the lock is fair or unfair.
So a fair mutex puts block
threads essentially into a
FIFO queue.
And the unlock operation
unblocks the thread that has
been waiting the longest.
So it makes it so that if you
try to acquire a lock, you
don't have some other thread
coming in and trying to access
that lock and getting
ahead of you.
It puts you in a queue.
So an unfair mutex lets any
blocked thread go next.
So the cheapest thing to
implement is a spinning,
non-reentrant, unfair lock--
mutex.
Those are the cheapest
ones to implement.
Very lightweight, very
easy to use.
The heavyweight ones
are a yielding,
reentrant, fair lock.
And of course, you can have
combinations, because all of
these have, as you can see,
different properties in terms
of convenience of use and
so forth, as well
as different overheads.
So there's some cases where the
overhead isn't a big deal
because it's not in the inner
loop of a program or a heavily
executed statement.
So let's take a look at one of
the simplest locks, which is a
simple spinning mutex.
This is the x86 code for
how to acquire a lock.
So let's run through this.
So we start out at the top.
And I check to see if the
mutex is 0, which is
basically, it's going to be 0
if it's free and 1 if it has
been acquired.
So we compare it.
If it's free, then I jump
to try to get the mutex.
Otherwise, I execute this PAUSE
instruction, and this
turns out to be a--
it's humorous.
It's x86 hack to un-confuse
the pipeline.
So it turns out that in this
case, if you don't have a
pause here--
which is no-op and
does nothing--
x86 mispredicts something or
whatever, and it's more time
consuming than if it doesn't
have that there.
The manual explains very little
about this hardware bug
except to say, put
in the pause.
So if you didn't get it, then
you jump to spin mutex, and
try again, check to
see if it's free.
Now, notice that we're going to
spin until it's free, and
then we're going to
try to get it.
Why not just try to
get it first?
Well, think about that while we
go through how to get it,
and then I'll ask it again.
Think about why it is that you
might want to get it first.
So if I want to get the
mutex, I first get a
value of 1 in my register.
And then I compute this exchange
operation, which
exchanges the value of the mutex
with the value of the--
with the one that I have.
So it exchanges the memory
location with the register.
Now, this is an expensive
operation--
exchange--
because it's an atomic exchange,
and it typically has
to go at least out
to L2 to do this.
So it's an expensive operation,
because it's a
read-modify-write operation.
I'm swapping my register
value with a value
that's in the mutex.
So it turns out that if it's
0, then it means I got it.
So I compare it with 0, and if
it's equal to 0, I go onto the
critical section.
When I'm done with the critical
section, I release
the mutex by basically storing
0 in there, because I'm the
only one who accesses the
mutex at this point.
If I didn't get it, if the
value is 1, notice that
because I'm swapping a 1 in,
even though the 1 got swapped
in, well, there was
a 1 there before.
So it basically did not affect
the value of the mutex.
But I discover, oh,
I don't have it.
Then we go all the way back
up there to spin mutex.
So here's the question.
Why do I need all this
preamble code?
Why not just go straight to
Get_Mutex, make the spin mutex
here be a jump to Get_Mutex?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Maybe it's because
the exchange is expensive.
PROFESSOR: Excuse me?
AUDIENCE: The exchange is--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, because the
exchange is expensive.
Exactly.
So this code here,
I can compare.
And as long as nobody's touching
anything, this
becomes just L1 memory
accesses.
Whereas here, it's going
to be at least L2 to do
the exchange operation.
So rather than doing that--
moreover, this one actually
changes the value.
So what happens when I change
the value of the mutex?
Even though I change it to the
same value, what happens in
order to do that exchange?
Remember from several
lectures ago.
What's going to happen when
I make an exchange there?
What does the hardware
have to do?
What's the hardware going to
do on any store to a shared
memory location, to a memory
location in shared memory that
is actually shared?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's
got to invalidate
all the other copies.
So if everybody spinning here--
imagine that you have
five guys spinning,
doing exchanges--
they're all creating all this
traffic of invalidations,
what's called an "invalidation
storm." So they create an
invalidation storm as they all
are invalidating each other so
that they can get access to it
so that they can change the
value themselves.
But up here, all I'm doing
is looking at the value.
All I'm doing is looking at the
value to see if it's free.
And it's not until the guy
actually frees the value that
it actually--
actually, this is interesting.
I think I wrote this with Intel
syntax, rather than
AT&T, didn't I?
The MOV mutex, 0 moves
0 into the mutex,
which is Intel syntax.
I probably should have converted
this to AT&T,
because that's what we're
generally using in the class.
I'll fix that before I
put the slides up.
Basically, I pulled this out
of the Intel manual.
So any questions about
this code?
Everybody see how it works?
It relies on this atomic
exchange operation.
And I'm going to end up sitting
here spinning until
maybe I can get access to it.
When I have a chance to get
access to it, I try to get it.
If I don't get it, I go
back to spinning.
How do I convert this
to a yielding mutex?
AUDIENCE: Instead
of having that
spinning mutex, you should--
you shouldn't have that.
You should just have something
that allows you to just
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so actually,
the way you do it is you
replace the PAUSE instruction.
Exactly what you're saying.
You've got the right
place in the code.
We basically call a yield.
And you can use, for example,
pthread_yield.
What it tells the operating
system is,
give up on this quantum.
You can schedule me out.
Somebody else can
be scheduled.
Now, if nobody else is there to
be scheduled, often you'll
just get control back, and
you'll jump again and give the
operating system another time.
Now, one of the things I've seen
in computer benchmarks
that use locking is that they
all use spin locks.
They never use the yielding,
because if you yield, then
when the lock comes free, you're
not going to be ready
to come back in.
You may be switched out.
So a common thing that all
these companies do when
they're vying for who's got the
fastest on this benchmark
or fastest on that benchmark
is they go through and they
convert all their yielding
mutexes into spinning mutexes,
then take their measurements,
when in fact, as a practical
matter, they can't actually
ship code that way.
So you'll see this kind of game
played where people try
to get the best performance
they can in some kind of
laboratory setting.
It's not the same as when
you're actually
doing a real thing.
So you have a choice here.
There's kind of a
tension here.
You'd like to claim the mutex
soon after it's released.
And you're not going to
get that if you yield.
At the same time, you want
to behave nicely
and waste few cycles.
So what's the strategy for being
able to accomplish both
of these goals?
So one of these goals is the
spinning mutex does a great
job of claiming the mutex soon
after it's released.
The yielding mutex behaves
nicely and wastes few cycles.
Is there the best
of both worlds?
There's certainly the worst
of both worlds, right?
What's the best of
both worlds?
How might we accomplish both
of these goals with small
modification to the
locking code?
So it turns out you
can get within a
factor of two of optimal.
How might you do that while
wasting few cycles?
So here's the idea.
Spin for a little while, and
then, if after a little while
you didn't manage to access
the mutex, then yield.
So that if the new mutex was
right there available to be
accessed, you could access it,
but you don't spin for an
indefinite amount of time.
So the question is, how
long do you spin?
So we're going to spin for a
little while and then yield.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, exactly.
So what you do is you spin for
basically as long as a context
switch takes.
So if you spin for as long as
it takes to do a context
switch and then do a context
switch, if the mutex became
immediately available, well,
you're only going to wait
double what you would
have waited.
And if in the meantime during
that first part where you're
spinning it becomes available,
you're not waiting at all any
longer than you actually
have to.
So in both cases, you're
waiting at
most a factor of two.
In one case, you're waiting
exactly the right.
The other, you can actually
wait a factor of two.
So this is a classic amortized
kind of argument, that you can
amortize the cost
of the spinning
to the context switch.
So spin until you spend as much
time as it would cost for
a context switch.
Then do the context switch.
Yet another voodoo parameter.
Yeah, so if the mutex is
released while spinning,
that's optimal.
If the mutex is released
after the yield, you're
within twice optimal.
Turns out that 2 is not
the optimal value.
There's a randomized algorithm
that makes it e over e minus 1
competitive where e is the base
of the natural logarithm.
So 2.7 divided by 1.7,
which is what?
Who's got a calculator?
2.7 divided by 1.7 is--
I should have calculated
this out.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It's about 1.6.
Good.
So it's better than 2.
People analyze these
things, right?
So any questions about
implementation of locks?
There are many other ways
of implementing locks.
There are other instructions
that people use.
They do things like
compare-and-swap is another
operation that's used.
There are some machines have
an operation called
load-linked/store-conditional,
which is not on the x86
architecture, but it is on
other architectures.
You'll see a lot of other things
of doing some kind of
atomic operation to
implement a lock.
Uniformly, they're expensive
compared to register
operations in particular or even
L1 accesses, typically,
in particular.
Any questions?
So now that we've decided that
we're going to use mutexes,
and we understand we're writing
non-deterministic code
and so forth, well, it turns out
there are a host of other
system anomalies that occur.
So locks are like, they're this
really evil mechanism
that works really well.
It feels so good that
nobody wants to stop
using it, even though--
but nobody has better ideas.
One of the most interesting
ideas in recent memory is the
idea of using what's called
"transactional memory," which
is basically where memory
operates like a database
transaction.
And it's allowed to abort, in
which case you roll it back
and retry it.
Yet, transactional memory has a
host of issues with it, and
still people use locks.
So let's talk about some of
the bad things that happen
when you start doing locks.
I'm going to talk about three of
them, deadlock, convoying,
and contention.
So deadlock is probably the most
important one, because it
has to do with correctness.
So you can have coded-- in fact,
I've seen people with
very fast code that has deadlock
potential in it.
It's like, if you deadlock, then
your average running time
is infinite if there's
a possibility
of a deadlock, right?
Because you're averaging
infinity with everything else
that you might run.
So it's not good to have
deadlock in your code,
regardless.
It's kind of like your
code seg faulting.
No decent code should
seg fault.
It should always catch its
own errors and terminate
gracefully.
It shouldn't just seg fault
in some circumstance.
Similarly, your code should
not deadlock.
So here's sort of a classical
instance of deadlock.
And deadlock typically occurs
when you hold more than one
lock at a time.
So here, this guy is going to
grab a lock A, going to grab a
lock B, then unlock B, unlock
A, and in there
do a critical section.
Why might I grab two locks?
What's the circumstance where I
might have code that looked
very similar to this?
Use case.
AUDIENCE: Two objects?
PROFESSOR: sorry?
AUDIENCE: You need
two objects.
PROFESSOR: You need
When might that occur?
AUDIENCE: Account
transactions.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, account
That's the classic one.
You want to move something from
this bank account to that
bank account.
And you want to make sure that
as you're updating it, nothing
else is occurring.
Another place this comes up all
the time is when you do
graph algorithms.
You always want to grab the edge
and have the two vertices
on each end of the edge not move
while you do something
across the edge.
So lots of cases there.
It turns out the order in
which you unlock things
doesn't matter, because you can
always unlock something.
You never hold up
for unlocking.
The problem with deadlock
is generally
how you acquire locks.
So in this example, Thread 2
grabs Lock B, then grabs Lock
A. So it might be, for example,
that you have some
random process that's at
the node of a graph.
And now it's going to
grab a lock on the
other end of an edge.
But you might have the guy at
the other end grabbing that
vertex and then grabbing
the one on your end.
And that's basically
the situation.
So what happens is Thread
1 acquires a lock here.
Thread 2 acquires that lock.
And now which one can go?
Neither of them.
You've got a deadlock.
Ultimate loss of performance.
So it's really a correctness
issue.
But you can view it, if you
really say, oh, correctness,
that's for sissies.
We do performance.
Well, it's still a performance
issue, because it's the
ultimate loss of performance.
In fact, that's probably true
of any correctness issue.
No, that's not true.
Sometimes you just get
the wrong number.
Here is a correctness
issue that
your code stops operating.
So there are three conditions
that are usually pointed to
that you need for deadlock.
The first is mutual exclusion.
Each thread claims exclusive
control over the resources
that it holds, in this case, the
resources being the locks.
So there's got to be some
resource that you're grabbing,
and that you're the only one
who gets to have it.
So in this case, it would
be the locks.
The second is non-preemption.
You don't let go of your
resources until you complete
your use of them.
So that means you can't let go
of a lock in a situation.
If you're actually
able to preempt--
so this piece of code over there
has grabbed locks, and
now I can come in and take them
away, then you may not
have a deadlock potential.
You may have other issues,
but you won't
have a deadlock potential.
And the third one is
circular waiting.
You have a cycle of threads in
which each thread is blocked
waiting for resources held by
the next thread in the cycle.
So let me illustrate this with
a very famous story that some
of you may have seen, because
it is so famous.
It's the dining philosophers
problem.
It's an illustrative story a
deadlock that was originally
told by Tony Hoare, based on
an examination question by
Edsger Dijkstra.
And the story has been
embellished over the years by
many retellers.
It's one of these things that
if you're a computer
scientist, you should know
this story just because
everybody knows this story.
So here's how the story goes,
at least my version of it.
I get to retell it now.
So each of n philosophers needs
the two chopsticks on
either side of his or
her plate to eat the
noodles on the plate.
So they're not worried about
germs here, by the way.
So you have five philosophers
in this case
sitting around the table.
There are five chopsticks
between them.
In order to eat, they need to
grab the two chopsticks on
either side.
Then they can eat.
Then they put them down.
So here's what philosopher
i does.
So in an infinite loop, the
philosopher does thinking,
because that's what
philosophers do.
Then it grabs the lock of
chopstick i and grabs the lock
of chopstick i plus 1.
That's the 1.
So if we index them, say, to the
left of the plate, this is
grabbing the chopstick to
the left of your plate.
This is grabbing the chopstick
to the right of your plate.
Then you can eat.
Then you release your
two chopsticks.
So here, that's the code.
And then you go back
to thinking.
I guess they have no other
bodily functions.
So the problem is, one day they
all pick up their left
chopsticks simultaneously.
Now they go to look for
their right chopstick.
It's not there.
So what happens?
They starve because their code
doesn't let them release--
there's no preemption, so they
can't release the chopstick
they've already got.
And we have a circular
waiting.
They have mutual exclusion.
Only one of them can have
a chopstick at a time.
And we have a circular waiting
thing, because everyone is
waiting for the philosopher
on the right.
Is that clear to everybody?
That's the dining philosophers
problem.
How do you fix this problem?
What are solutions to
fixing this problem?
The problem being that you'd
like them to eat indefinitely.
AUDIENCE: You can index the
chopstick and say that
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, you can pick
the smaller index first.
So in general, that means
everybody would grab the one
on their left, then the one on
their right, except for the
guy who's going between
0 and n minus 1.
They would do n minus
1 and then 0.
1 first, and then 0.
Sorry.
They would do 0 first,
and then n minus 1.
[INAUDIBLE]
Let me say that more
precisely.
So this is a classic way
to prevent deadlock.
Suppose that we can linearly
order the mutexes in some
order so that whenever a thread
that holds a mutex Li
and attempts to lock another
mutex Lj, we have it that Li
goes before Lj in
the ordering.
Then no deadlock can occur.
So always grab the resource so
if they can all order the
resources--
so they're always grabbing them
in some subsequence of
this order, so they're always
grabbing one that's larger and
larger and larger, and you're
never going back and grabbing
one smaller, than you
have no deadlock.
Here's why.
Suppose you have a
cycle of waiting.
You have a deadlock
has occurred.
Let's look at the thread in
the cycle that holds the
largest mutex that's called
Lmax in the ordering.
So whatever is in
the ordering.
And suppose that it's waiting on
a mutex L held by the next
threat in the cycle.
That's the condition.
Well, then it must be that Lmax
falls before L, because
we're gathering them always
in an increasing order.
But that contradicts the fact
that Lmax is the largest.
So a deadlock cannot occur.
Questions?
Is this clear?
Who's seen this before?
A few people.
OK.
Is this clear?
So if you grab them in
increasing order, then there's
always some guy that has the
largest one, and nobody is
holding one larger.
So he can always grab
the next one.
So in this case of the dining
philosophers, what we can do
is grab the minimum of i and
i plus 1 mod n and then the
maximum of i and
i plus 1 mod n.
That gives us the same
two chopsticks.
And in fact, for most of the
philosophers, it's exactly the
same order.
But for one guy, it's
a different order.
It ends up being the guy who
would normally have done n
minus 1 and 0.
Instead, he does 0, n minus 1.
So in some sense, it's like
having a left-handed
person at the table.
You grab your left, then your
right, except for one guy does
right and then left.
And that fixes it, OK?
That fixes it.
Good.
So that's basically the dining
philosophers problem.
That's one way of fixing it.
There are actually other
ways of doing it.
One of the problems with this
particular solution is you
still can have a long
chain of waiting.
So there are other schemes that
you can use where, for
example, if every other one
grabs left and then right and
then right and then left and
then left and then right and
then right and left and so
forth, you can end up making
it so that nobody has to
wait to go all the
way around the circle.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, that would be
a preemption type of thing,
where I grab one, and if I
didn't get it in time, I
release it and then try again.
When you have something like
that, there's an issue.
It's, how do you set
the timeout amount?
And the second issue that you
get into when you do timeouts
is, how do you know you don't
then repeat exactly the same
thing and convert a
deadlock situation
into a livelock situation?
So a livelock situation is
where they're not making
progress, but they're all
busily working, thinking
they're making progress.
So you timeout.
Let's try again.
What makes you think that the
guys that are deadlocking
aren't going to do exactly
the same thing.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: And exactly.
And in fact, that's actually
a workable scheme.
And there are schemes
that do it.
Now, that's much more
complicated.
Sometimes has more overhead,
especially because things
become available.
And it's like, no, you're busy
raiding some random amount of
time before you try again.
So this is, by the way, the
protocol that is used on the
Ethernet for doing contention
resolution.
It's what's called "exponential
backoff." And
various backoff schemes are
used in order to allow
multiple things acquire
mutually-exclusive access to
something without having to
have a definite ordering.
So there are solutions, but
they definitely get more
heavyweight.
It's not lightweight.
Whereas if you can prevent
deadlock, that's really good,
because you just simply
do the natural thing.
And that tends to
be pretty quick.
But yeah, all I'm doing is
sort of covering the
introduction to all
these things.
There are books written on
this type of subject.
Any other questions about
dining philosophers and
deadlock and so forth?
Now let me tell you how
to deadlock Cilk++.
So here's a code that
will deadlock
Cilk++, or has the potential.
You might run it a bunch of
times, it looks fine.
Here's what we've done is
main routine spawns foo.
Here's foo down here.
All foo does is grab a lock
and then unlocks it.
Empty critical section.
It could do something
in there.
It doesn't matter.
Then the main grabs a lock,
does a cilk_sync and then
unlocks it.
So what can go wrong here?
Notice, by the way, this
is only one lock, L.
There's not two locks.
So you can deadlock Cilk by
just introducing one lock.
So here's sort of
what's going on.
Let's let this be the main
thread and this be foo.
And this will represent
a lock acquire, and
this is a lock release.
So what happens is we
perform the lock
acquire here in the parent.
First, we spawned here, then
we acquire the lock here.
And now foo tries to get access
to the lock, and it
can't because why?
The main routine has the lock.
Now what happens?
The main routine proceeds to the
sync, and what does it do
at the sync?
It waits for all children
to be done.
And notice now we've created a
cycle of waiting, even though
we didn't use a lock.
Main waits, but foo is never
going to complete, because
it's waiting for the main thread
to release it, the main
strand here to release it,
the main function here.
Is that clear?
So you can deadlock Cilk too
by doing non-deterministic
programming.
So here's the methodology that
will help you not do that.
So what's bad here?
What's bad is holding the
lock across the sync.
That's bad.
So don't do that.
Doctor, my head hurts.
Well, stop hitting it.
So don't hold mutexes
across Cilk syncs.
Hold mutexes only within
strands, only with
serially-executing
pieces of code.
Now, it turns out that you can
hold it across syncs and so
forth, but you have
to be careful.
And I'm not going to get
into the details of
how you can do that.
If you want to figure that out
on your own, that's fine.
And then you're welcome
to try to do that
without deadlocking something.
Turns out, basically, if you
grab the lock before you do
any spawns, and then released
it after the Cilk
sync, you're OK.
You're generally, in
that case, OK.
So as always, try to avoid using
mutexes, but that's not
always possible.
In other words, try to do
deterministic programming.
That helps too.
And on your homework, you had an
example of where it is that
deterministic programming can
actually do a pretty good job.
The next anomaly I want to
talk about is convoying.
Once again, another thing
that can happen.
This one is actually quite an
embarrassment, because the
original MIT Cilk system that
we built had this bug in it.
So we had this bug.
So let me show you what it is.
So here's the idea.
We're using random work-stealing
where each thief
grabs a mutex on its
victim's deck.
So in order to steal from a
victim, it grabs a mutex on
the victim.
And now, once it's got the
mutex, it now is in a position
to migrate the work that's
on that victim to
actually steal the work.
And you want to do
that atomically.
You don't want two guys getting
in there trying to
steal from each other.
So if the victim's deck is
empty, the thief releases the
mutex and tries again
at random.
That makes sense.
If there's nothing there to be
stolen, then just released the
mutex and move on.
If the victim's deck contains
work, the thief then steals
the topmost frame and then
releases the mutex.
Where's the performance
bug here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
trying to steal from
each other.
Like A steals from B, B steals
from C, C steals from D, and
they all have locks on each
other, and then--
PROFESSOR: No, because in that
case, they'll each grab the
deck from each other, discover
it's empty, and release it.
OK, let me show the bug.
It is very subtle.
As I say, we didn't realize we
had this bug until we noticed
some codes on which we
weren't getting the
speedups we were expecting.
Let me show you where
this bug comes from.
Here's the problem.
At the startup, most thieves
will quickly converge on the
worker P0 containing
the initial
strand, creating a convoy.
So let me show you
how that happens.
So here we have the startup of
our Cilk system where one guy
has work, and all these
are workers that
have no work to do.
So what happens?
They all try to steal
at random.
In this case, we have this guy
tries to steal from this
fellow, this guy tries
to steal from
this fellow, et cetera.
So of these, this guy, this
guy, and that guy all are
going to discover there's
nothing there to be stolen,
and they're going to
repeat the process.
This guy and this guy, there's
going to be some arbitration.
And one of them is going
to get the lock.
Let's assume it's
this one here.
So what happens is, this
guy gets the lock.
What does this guy do?
He's going to wait.
Because he's trying to
acquire the lock.
He can't acquire the
lock, so he waits.
So then what happens?
This guy now wants to steal
the work from this fellow.
So he steals a little
bit of work.
Then these guys now,
what do they do?
They try again.
So this guy tries to steal from
there, this guy tries to
steal from there, this one
happens to try to steal there.
This one sees there's work
there to be done, so
what does it do?
It waits.
But these guys then try again.
Maybe a little bit more
stuff is moved.
They try again.
A little bit more stuff.
But every time one tries and
gets stuck on P0 while we're
doing that whole transfer, they
all are ending up getting
stuck waiting for this
guy to finish.
And now, we've got work over
here, but how many guys are
going to be trying to
steal from this guy?
None.
They're all going to be trying
to steal from this one,
because they all have done a
lock acquisition, and they're
sitting there waiting.
So this is called convoying,
where they all pile up on one
thing, and now resolving
that convoy.
So this was a bug in startup.
Why wasn't Cilk starting
up fast?
Initially, we just thought, oh,
there's system kinds of
things going on there.
So the work now gets distributed
very slowly,
because each one is going to
serially try to get this work,
and they're not going
to try to get the
work from each other.
What you want is that on the
second phase, half the guys
might start hitting this one.
So you get some kind of
exponential distribution of
the work in kind of
a tree fashion.
And that's what theory
says would happen.
But the theory is usually done
without worrying about what
happens in the implementation
of the lock.
What's the fix for this?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can you just basically
shove-- when you're
transferring, you should also
say, I have work, so that
people [INAUDIBLE] waiting for
that guy to [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You could do that,
but in the meantime, it could
be that the attempt to steal
goes so much faster than the
actual getting of the work,
you're still going to get half
the guys locked up
on this one.
And the other half might be
locked up on this one.
Good idea.
What other things can we do?
AUDIENCE: Can you check
how many people
are waiting on the--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so the
idea is we don't want
to use a lock operation.
So here's the idea.
We use a non-blocking function
that's usually called
"try_lock," rather than "lock."
try_lock attempts to
acquire the mutex.
If it succeeds, great.
It's got it.
If it fails, it doesn't
go to spin.
It simply returns and
say, I failed.
It doesn't go to spin or
to yield or anything.
It just says, oh, I
failed, and tells
that back to the user.
But it doesn't attempt
to block.
So with try_lock now, what can
these other processors do?
They do a try_lock--
yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
Instead of waiting there on
the guy that they fail on,
they pick another random
one to steal from.
So they'll just continually
try to get it.
If they get it, then they
can do their operation.
If they don't get it, they just
look elsewhere for work.
So that's what it does.
It just tries to steal again at
random, rather than blocking.
And that gets rid of this
convoying problem.
As I say, dangerous programming,
because we didn't
even know we had a problem.
Just our code was slower than
it could have been.
Questions about convoying?
So try_lock is actually a very
convenient thing to use.
So in many cases, you may find
that, hey, rather than waiting
on something with nothing to do,
let me go see if there's
something else I can
do in the meantime.
Contention.
So here's an example of a code
where I want to add up some
function of the elements
of some array.
So here I've got a value of
n, which is a million.
And I have a type X. So we have
a compute function, which
takes a pointer to a--
did I do this right?
To value V. So anyway, my C++
is not as good as my C, and
for those who don't know,
my C isn't very good.
So anyway, we have an array
of type X of n elements.
And what I do is I set result
to be 0, and then I have a
loop here which basically goes
and adds into result the
result of computing on each
element of the array.
And then it outputs
the result.
Does everybody understand what's
going on in the code?
It's basically compute on every
element in the array,
take the result, add all
those results together.
We want to parallelize this.
So let's parallelize that.
What looks like the best
opportunity for parallelizing?
Yeah, we go after the for and
make it be a cilk_for.
Let's add all those guys up.
And what's the problem
with that?
We get a race.
What's the race on?
AUDIENCE: Result.
PROFESSOR: Result.
They're all updating
result in parallel.
Oh, I know how to
resolve a race.
Let's just put a
lock around it.
So here we have the race.
First, let's analyze this.
So the work here is order n.
What is the span?
AUDIENCE: Log n.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, the span is log
n for the control of the
stuff here, because this
is all constant time.
So the running time here is
order n over P plus log n.
If you remember the greedy
scheduling, it's going to be
something like this, because
this is the work
over P plus the span.
So we expect that if n over P
is big compared to log n,
we're going to do pretty well,
because we have parallelism
over log n.
So let's fix this bug.
So this is fast code, but
it's incorrect code.
So let's fix it by getting
rid of this race.
So what we'll do is we'll
put a lock before.
We'll introduce a mutex L, and
we'll lock L before we add to
the result, and then
we'll unlock it.
So first of all, this is a bad
way to do it, because what I
really should do is first
compute the result of my array
and then lock, add it to the
result, and then unlock so
that we lessen the time
that I'm holding the
lock in each iteration.
Nevertheless, this is still
a lousy piece of code.
Why's that?
AUDIENCE: It's still
serialized.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's
Every update to result here
has to go on serially.
They're n accesses.
They're all going to
go one at a time.
So my running time, instead of
being n over log n, is going
to be something like order n.
Believe me, I have seen many
people write code where they
essentially do exactly this.
They take something, they make
it parallel, they have a race
bug, they fix it with a mutex.
Bad idea, because then
we end up with
contention on this mutex.
What's the right way to
parallelize this?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Maybe you could
have each [INAUDIBLE]
have result as an array and
one place [INAUDIBLE].
And then at the end,
some of all the--
PROFESSOR: But won't that
be n elements to sum up?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: So basically,
have, say.
Eight results, instead
of having--
PROFESSOR: For each thread.
Good.
So that each one could keep it
local to its own thread.
Now, of course, that involves me
knowing how many processors
I'm running on.
So now, if that number
changes or whatever--
there's a way of doing it
completely processor
obliviously.
AUDIENCE: Divide and conquer.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, do divide
and conquer.
Add up recursively the first
half of the elements, add up
the second half of
the elements,
and add them together.
Next time, we're going to see
yet another mechanism for
doing that, which gets the
kind of performance that
you're mentioning but without
having to rewrite the For loop
as divide and conquer.
We'll see that next time.
So in this case, we have lock
contention that takes away our
parallelism.
Unfortunately, very little is
known about lock contention.
The greedy scheduler, you can
show that it achieves T1 over
P plus T infinity plus B where
B is the bondage, that is, if
you add the total time of
all critical sections.
That's a lousy bound, because
it says, even if they're
locked by different locks, you
still add up the total time of
all the critical sections.
And generally, although you can
improve this in special
cases, the general theory for
understanding contention is
not understood very well.
And this upper bound is weak,
but little is known about lock
contention.
Very little is known about
lock contention.
So to conclude, always
write deterministic
programs, unless you can't.
Always write deterministic
Great.